i also really like this kind of hero
piece that you're accentuating
the folks at disney never fail to
surprise us even after watching the
movie
there's a lot of work that goes into
making a disney movie
even a single frame of animation can
take days of hard work
the animators at disney definitely like
to make things as detailed as possible
there's plenty of things you may not
have noticed from movies you may have
watched
dozens of times here are just some of
those hidden small details did you see
that
in this scene from tangled where
rapunzel has flynn tied up to a chair
with her hair there's a close-up shot of
flynn's eyes that reveals just how
committed to detail disney tends to be
in a blink and you'll miss it moment
you'll be able to catch rapunzel's
reflection
in the whites of flynn's eyes just as
they dart to the right
would you stop that after escaping from
the giant sassy crab known as tamatoa
maui's magical hook suffers from a
malfunction causing him to transform
into a half-human and half-shark hybrid
if you look closely you'll notice that
maui's trademark tattoo of himself has
also been transformed into a shark
ah shark head as we all probably know by
now
aladdin is based off a collection of
folk tales popular in the middle east
titled 1001 nights an interesting small
tidbit
pays homage to the origins of the source
material whenever robin williams genie
is shown writing
he is writing from the right to the left
this pays homage to the fact that arabic
is traditionally written from the right
to the left
if you've ever been to an arcade you'll
probably notice that almost
all the games have a high score the
fixit felix jr cabinet in wreck-it ralph
is no different
the high score of the game read 12050
which if you are a hardcore disney
fanatic you might recognize this as the
birthday of walt disney himself
december 5th 1901 think you can top that
high score
in zootopia nick's employment
application to become a police officer
has a fun little gag
under the question have you ever been
arrested you'll see that nick initially
checked off yes
before scribbling it out and checking no
seems a bit suspicious
hopefully that didn't come up in his
interview with chief bogo
not now beauty and the beast's large
cast of living castle objects
all have some pretty pun worthy names
while there's the obvious ones like mrs
potts lumiere and cogsworth
there's also some that only true experts
will catch
sultan the beast's transformed pooch is
an ottoman
this is actually a historical reference
regarding the fact that sultans were the
rulers in the ottoman empire
while casting her spell to transform
herself into her human alter ego vanessa
you may have noticed that ursula grabs a
butterfly what you may not have noticed
is that vanessa just so happens to be
the name of a genus of butterfly
well played disney well played
the sea witch the mobile hanging above
baby rapunzel's crib has items that
correspond to the film's plot
there's a horse representing flynn's
trusty steed maximus
a chameleon for rapunzel's chameleon pal
pascal
a duck for the snuggly duckling tavern
because who doesn't love ducklings
an angel for the man dressed as cupid at
said tavern
and a blue bird for the birds that fly
around rapunzel when she leaves the
tower for the first
time spoiler alert i can't believe
i did that as belle's father maurice
finds himself lost in the woods he comes
across
a faded wood sign pointing in various
directions
the faded names on the signs are names
of cities in california
one of the names on the signs reads
valencia which just so happens to be the
location of cal
arts a school where many of disney's top
animators got their start
the other sign reads anaheim which is
the location of the disneyland resort
that's a long way away from beast's
castle
let's go this way riley certainly has a
lot of memories in inside out but some
of them are actually from other pixar
movies
in one scene you can see two memories
next to each other that represent the
wedding scene from up
as well as carl and ellie's house these
are riley's memories and they're mostly
happy you'll notice not to brag
while on their way to ebay ralph and
vanellope encounter several spam-filled
pop-up ads
with one of them promoting sassy
housewives that want to meet ralph
if you look closely at the ad you'll
recognize a familiar face
aunt cass from big hero 6 it'd probably
be wise of ralph
not to click on that ad sassy housewives
wanna meet you
in the opening musical number of the
princess and the frog down in new
orleans there's a little hidden detail
within this overview shot of the city
if you look over to the right you'll see
a woman airing out a carpet that looks
very similar to aladdin's magic carpet
that begs the question how did it manage
to get
all the way to new orleans come on
come on out we're not gonna hurt you
during the very memorable scene which
finds vanellope meeting all the disney
princesses while visiting oh my disney
there's plenty of little hidden details
one of those is located on the vanity
table behind aurora
where you'll notice ariel's candlestick
and a box of thingamabobs
she's got 20 of those you know i don't
see
how a world that makes such wonderful
things
on the streets of lilo and nani's
hawaiian home of kawaii a chinese
restaurant can be seen between the
farmers market and television store
the restaurant's name in question mulan
walk if that wasn't enough mulan
goodness there's also a poster for mulan
hung up on
nani's bedroom wall nani must be a big
fan
love judy hopps music player has
plenty of pun worthy names resembling
some very popular musicians
some of these names include fleetwood
yak fur fighters
canine west and the beagles to top that
off gazelle's album
features songs with titles that sound
very similar to some classic disney
tunes from
let it goat to part of your wool
i'm gazelle welcome to zootopia as
tarzan's jungle friends play with the
human's belongings turk can be seen
playing with a tea set as if it were an
instrument
the teapot actually resembles mrs potts
from beauty and the beast
how she wound up in the jungle however
still remains to be seen
see i told you science geeks are sure to
catch this hidden detail in big hero 6.
honey lemon's tech based super suit
features a purse that if you look
closely has the periodic table of
elements on it how
fashionable i love it as the muses sing
about the planets aligning in hercules
only six planets are shown instead of
eight
this is actually because the ancient
greeks only knew of five other planets
outside of earth that could be seen by
the human eye
now that's commitment the planets
will align hidden mickeys are scattered
across
many of disney's movies tv shows and
even their theme parks
in this shot in the opening of the
emperor's new groove an overhead shot
shows that the plates being used by
couscous servants have
food on them shaped like green hidden
mickeys
now you threw off my groove
in the opening when you wish upon a star
scene in this disney classic
the bookshelves that jiminy cricket
reads the story of pinocchio from has
two familiar books
those books are for alice in wonderland
and peter pan
both of those disney later turned into
movies over 10 years later
what a build-up as anna greets visitors
outside of the castle before elsa's
coronation you'll catch that she walks
by two very familiar looking characters
in fact these two characters are
rapunzel and flynn with the princess
sporting her new short hairdo
does this mean anna and elsa's parents
showed up for rapunzel and flynn's
wedding
did i ever tell you i've got a thing for
brunettes
losing his dramatic battle with the
beast gaston begins to fall from the
castle
in a blink and you'll miss it shot you
see that gaston's eyes have skulls
flashing
ultimately predicting his untimely fate
[Music]
during king triton's introduction in the
little mermaid several of the background
characters in the audience are some very
notable disney alumni
the beloved muppet kermit the frog can
be seen sitting in one corner while
mickey donald and goofy can also be seen
watching in the audience
disney and the muppets have to represent
somehow
yes watch out ted here i come as nani
prepares to sign stitch's adoption
papers you'll notice that this is no
ordinary document in fact the adoption
document is
actually a thank you note to the
production and creative team behind the
film
it makes you wonder how many of them
paused the movie to read it
i like them come here boy after pixar's
cars
lost best animated film at the oscars to
the warner brothers produced motion
capture flick
happy feet pixar included a small jab at
the end of their subsequent film
ratatouille the label reads that the
film is 100
genuine animation with no motion capture
used and reminds
everybody that the studio's films are
all animated by hand
instead of just using motion capture
tough but fair
what are you talking about i don't know
disney sure loves to hide some hidden
goodies in all their films and it's
always so much fun to find them
from characters from other films making
cameos to pun worthy names
the mouse house doesn't disappoint
what's your favorite hidden detail in a
disney movie